I heard you touch on this in another
interview and I'm wondering if you can
elaborate that everything is a cliche
and it's all been done before so how do
we keep films fresh it's it's an
interesting thing because I don't think
a filmmaker sets out to I want to do a
fresh approach to food I want to be a
fresh approach to a romantic comedy I
think what you do if you're doing a good
service to storytelling is try to do it
with the best experiences that you've
got with the knowledge and knowing that
people don't like to be preached to with
the knowledge and knowing that oh I want
to make a strong female character and
it's written strong but I'd like to make
it even stronger because I'd like her to
make a statement about in this
particular case food and I also think
you know cliches it's an it's part of
the vernacular of human communications
so it's it's not a bad thing to make a
cliche people have compared this movie
to chef I think who wouldn't be more
flattered than that or a reviewer just
reviewed and and compared it to chalk a
lot chalk a lot was it was a was a major
influence on me choosing to make this
movie because I wanted it to be a
discovery I wanted it to be warm I
wanted it to be rich and I wanted it to
be real but you know it's funny there's
a there's a there's a TV show on it on
Amazon right now that's basically a
mimic and I'm not going to tell you the
name under the Tuscan Sun and it's all
filmed in Greece and it's unbelievably
magically done it takes place in the
1930s and I look at that and I say to
myself you know is that a cliche is that
a exploitation not at all it's just
another way to tell the story that is
about place I want to go watch that it's
a TV show I want to go watch it every
time I you know I feel certain need to
see the warmth and you know to be
perfectly blunt with you I am NOT an
exterior filmmaker typically so for me
to want to go to New Mexico and exploit
that the biggest compliment you could
give me is comparing it to a movie like
sideways
that took parts of Northern California
and made it popular because the movie
was filmed there
I mean Taos I think will be a major
benefactor if the movies successful but
cliches versus remakes how are they
different I'm saying actually this it's
one in the same because you go out today
to make a remake of you know any of
these these TV shows that are being made
now I think you can temporize it you
know and you try to make it more
conducive to what's going on in the
world today and hopefully try to you
know try to do a better job than the
original and it's interesting because I
think that Hollywood's got a formula for
doing that now and much of it has to do
with bringing in the right writers and
the right directors because it is an art
form and it's failed as much as it
succeeded so cliches you know I think
are just part of the vernacular if
someone's always gonna say to you you
know have you seen this it's just like
that I just did it so you know you know
the old story that George Lucas once
would say there's only really seven or
ten stories ever told you know all these
stories have been told before so your
ability to catapult it into a different
look a different drama a different tone
is what makes you know this also
exciting I mean it's funny the movie
that I was about to do was a Holocaust
themed movie but it took place in the in
the 90s and what motivated me to do this
movie is it's not about the Holocaust
and because I didn't want to do a movie
about the Holika I wanted to do a movie
about psychology and about the the
concept of the aftermath of the wall
coming down and that was appealing to me
is it a cliche well if you do what I did
as a filmmaker and looked at everything
that was on either Netflix or Amazon
about these concepts of
of World War two or even World War one
you know you walk Oh with just a you
know a huge jar full of wonderful
content and then you say I don't want to
anything like that I want to use
something different
is it a cliche I don't know you know
some people would say it is so a cliche
and Yin keeping a fresh voice how does
somebody keep a fresh voice we always
hear that you know I been reading a
biography on David Foster Wallace and
how he had this fresh voice at that time
and he was breaking all the rules you
think that could really be done today I
didn't realize he'd I do I do and
essentially because my movie is of
romantic comedy that takes place
surrounding food and I'm here to tell
you with no problem dropping names
because the chef's table on Netflix is
just a brilliantly produced show I
wouldn't want to do it but I love to
watch it and it takes place all around
the world and they broke all the rules
because there's a million shows about
food so why is that one different
because the filmmakers are great
storytellers they take you to the far
corners of a Buddhist monk in South
Korea I mean who would have done that
and they have drones and they have
technology that they're using to make
this just a not only a delightful
one-hour special but you're there you
feel it but isn't it just the same as
what you know well I've been doing this
for so many years I can go back to the
beginning where where they had these
food shows and you got the people Martha
Stewart cooking and and then they show
stills behind her of Tuscany or wherever
the food she's cooking and there's
really no difference in the storytelling
except for for how they went about
executing it
you